I've always let the clothes like speak
to me I've never been confined by
whether this was in the men's section of
the women's section like if I feel that
this should be on my body then it should
be on my body it's always been a lot for
people to comprehend you know it took a
long time for her to get used to it but
like you know it's just always who I was
is there anything else that you want to
believe on the read table talk because
we were so inspired when you opened up
you know what I had a great time with
that but I actually just managed to
willow to in Paris and I love her so
much I love what they are doing I hope
that I get to get a chance to come back
and like talk again I love a good moment
to just kind of reveal certain different
truths about myself that most people
don't know and so I really feel like
they need to have more shows like like
theirs and I'm really glad that they're
capitalizing on that and they're doing
so well and they're so successful and I
you know I wish them the best and I'm
and I was just waiting in to come back I
have a lot to unpack thank you for
inspiring us with the look your life
everything EJ Johnson stepped out in
style at MCM s global flagship store in
LA opening up about his revealing read
Table Talk with Jada pinkett-smith and
more I want to talk to you about your
first memory and in fashion and stepping
out of your comfort zone because you're
someone we look to for that New York I
moved to New York that's really when it
all happened for me and my freshman year
of college in 2010 now I feel old but
that's really when you know it all kind
of hit for me and I really started to
step outside my comfort zone and
pressure gender brows boundaries about
clothes and you know really just come
into my own and then I've been walking
with it ever since and it's been amazing
[Music]
[Applause]